car honneur aussi merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france à l'heure sans
surprise la situation au mali occupera
une large partie des débats alors oui
même si j'ai regardé juste avant de
rentrer en contact avec vous que les
débats porteront plus volontiers sur la
relance du processus d'un prêt de
l'intégration après la copie de 19
donc pour l'instant on ne sait pas
exactement quelle est quel est l'ordre
du jour ni à quelles seront quels seront
les questions concernant le mamie qui
seront abordés bien qu'on sache un petit
peu dans quelques prédispositions la
cedeao est à l'heure actuelle est
justement quelle est la position de la
cedeao face aux manifs face à ce qui se
passe actuellement
mais à écouter la cdo est dans une
position de sanctions comme vous l'avez
vu très rapidement il ya une ligne dure
qui s'est créée autour d'alassane
ouattara et d'alpha condé qui a été
favorable à des sanctions des sanctions
qui ont été contestés par le président
de la guinée-bissau tout autant que par
le président du sénégal
il reste à savoir que néanmoins cette
cdm on reste sur une ligne qui est celle
d'une transition rapide et une
transition du pouvoir à l'endroit de des
civils
est-ce que selon vous tous les chefs
d'état de la cedeao parlent d'une même
voix s qui sont unanimes face à la
situation manie bien comme je viens de
vous voulez écrire nous mais en tous cas
les décisions sont là elles sont en acte
et il faut donc en tenir compte et
savoir que de toute façon
eh bien eh bien ils attendent
effectivement un retour d
des civils au pouvoir on note également
que la france
comment dire a été dans cette direction
si elle a condamné le coup d'état elle s
est rangée assez rapidement du côté de
la real politique en demandant un
transfert rapide du pouvoir vers vers
les civils donc vous voyez bien
globalement d'un côté et de l'autre il y
à un demande de processus électoral qui
se profile rapide alors c'est vrai
rapide pour certains cela implique 12
mois est ce que ce sont vraiment les
questions qui se posent à l'heure
actuelle pour les maliennes et les
maliens vraisemblablement pas on voit
bien que la junte hinault cnsp donc le
comité national de salut public
et quand elle n'y est entré dans une
phase de négociation avec pour volonté
est bien d'en extraire une feuille de
route avec des chantiers prioritaires à
identifier l'identification également
des acteurs susceptibles et bien
d'apporter des réponses des éléments de
réponse pour des réformes structurelles
etc structurantes pour l'avenir du mali
est peut-être le processus électoral qui
ne saurait être synonyme de démocratie
est bien pourra être traitée en
parallèle
alors aujourd'hui on ne peut pas jouer
évidemment l'avenir du mali sur
sur un coup de dés et on verra venir en
fonction de cette feuille de route que
qui sera établi par la junte en
convergence avec les différents acteurs
manière qui participe donc ces journées
de réflexion ce qu'il en sortira
et quelle sera la méthodologie est donc
le cas au rétro planning qui pourra être
adapté à l'issue de ces concertations
voilà donc pour l'instant la question de
la temporalité semble secondaire par
rapport à ces questions qui qui depuis
de nombreuses années se pose au mali
caroline rossi merci d'avoir être avec
nous en direct vous êtes chercheuse
aleris et docteur en histoire de
l'afrique contemporaine merci